Fuck man.
Is that this?
So that's the scariest thing in Africa
in terms of like interacting with human
beings. You know what the scariest
thing in Africa is? Mosquitoes. Oh yeah,
of course. Right? Like all, all, all
stuff. You can see all the big wildlife,
you can kind of feel it out and you
put yourself in the bad situations.
Mosquitoes, there's nothing.
You know what I mean?
You just know you can do about
it. Yeah. My Buddy Justin wren,
he a runs fight for the forgotten charity.
They build wells for the pygmies. Okay.
And He's been bitten. He's
gotten malaria three times. Yeah.
And one time he got it like
he didn't even get bit again.
The malaria just returned.
If so,
it must be in some way systemic,
I think. I believe it is. I don't,
I don't never had it. Knock on
wood, my grandfather had it,
but I know that it's it. It wrecks
you for life. Like it can come back.
You can get it again. It stays with
you. I think that's his situation.
And he's a professional athlete.
He's actually a fighter for Bella.
He's one of their, a heavyweight
contenders. Damn. Yeah.
Has he said that it's affected his
performance? No, I don't think it has.
I think a, I think he's been okay with
it. You know, he received treatment,
but it's definitely rectum on three
separate occasions where he was, you know,
basically on death's door. Right. And one
of them was, and he's flying back. Damn.
You know,
and he's just sweating and it just
rotting out and the inside was awful.
Say you want to ask what scares me? That's
it. Like I would, I'll take a hippo,
a snake, a crock of Leopard. Anything
over that? Yeah. Malaria is terrifying.
You see, malaria has killed more people
than anything ever. Really. You know,
malaria has killed half the people that
have ever died. Oh my God, that's insane.
Just make sure that's right. There
might be bullshit too. That sounds good.
I think it's real. I think, I think
we actually have googled this before.
The malaria is literally killed 50%
of all the people that have ever done.
That's insane.
Yeah.
It's not to me that people were
worried about so many different things.
And you should be worried about Miskito.
Exactly. Well, apparently they're,
they're trying to genetically
engineer mosquitoes to, uh, to,
to be void of devoid of malaria
and they hybridize. Right.
So my understanding is the way that it's
done is they genetically engineer at
the males to reproduce with the females,
which are the malaria carriers and then
the offspring of that generation can no
longer carry malaria. Yeah. Okay.
Malaria killed half the people who've
ever lived. That is bonkers. It's a myth.
Yeah.
It would have had to kill.
It says like five and a half million
people on average per year every year for
all of human history. And that's not,
I think it kills half a million a year.
I think the real numbers
like half the size,
it would have to be five and a half ago.
So it was just one of those things
that people say, yeah, I like it.
I should probably shut the fuck
up. But what else is new? Um,
so how many people have they killed?
A lot. Okay, we'll go with a lot.
So other other does.
I mean like typhoid and shit.
Isn't there like a fucking case of
typhoid in California now, right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Well we've got some weird situations in
this country with measles returning and
polio returning. All these came
in. Yeah. What the Hell Nah.
Outbreaks expands and La and Long
Beach. Jesus. Cool me down here, Joe.
Congratulations. There's no, it was my
hand was sweaty when they're different,
but it's different. It's
similar but different. It's
not typhoid. It's typhus. Oh.
Fleet borne disease that can be treated
with antibiotics or something. Yeah.
I'm terrified of Lyme disease
to have you had line? No,
but I have a gang of friends that
have had it and it wrecks them. Well,
you spend a ton of time hiking
around and stuff out here. Yeah.
Well California doesn't have much Lyme,
but east coast it's horrific.
It's like everybody that spends time
outdoors in the northeast seems to get it.
Yeah. And I don't know
what you can do about that.
There was a vaccine that they
were doing for awhile, but um,
one of my friends,
her dad actually got Lyme
disease from the vaccine. Huh?
Like he didn't have it got vaccinated and
Mondo catching it from the vaccine and
I think they were like, okay,
fuck this proxy. Sorry. Cause
they had it for a while.
I've done, that's no fun. Yeah.